my name is tamari ostrov and i am a
junior in Stern college studying
computer science as sort of a growing
millennial I've become increasingly
interested and how data analysis that
has just increased dramatically over the
past 10 20 years will affect my life and
the lives of my peers data sources are
growing much larger and more complex as
we know but there's very little that's
known about the algorithms that are
gathering and sorting these data this
data especially by large companies that
are utilizing data to recommend
different information to us I would like
to specifically focus on how this
affects the political world and recently
you know different companies like
Facebook and Twitter have come under
fire for producing really outrageously
radical or even factually inaccurate
data to very targeted audiences that
means that specific media coming from
political areas are being shown to
specific people and oftentimes not
everyone is seeing the same thing and
this can have really really dramatic
effects on how we form opinions and this
is especially prevalent to younger
voters who are very impressionable
specifically through social media and
just online resources in general I would
like to specifically focus on how
rhetoric is used both in search engines
analysis and interpretation of data and
how that is also used when we search for
things what words are we using and how
is that impacting what we see so first
let's just ask sort of the important
preliminary questions which is what data
is being shared over the internet right
obviously there are millions of websites
articles and videos that are available
for us to view and to click on but no
one person can see all of these things
so what influences the position of a
given news source in your search results
or in your news feed and where do
advertisements write this has been sort
of the hot topic where do add to fit
into this so what are you seeing first
just based on content and also sort of
based on how much maybe advertisers are
paying how does this influence their
position on the screen again I would
like to specifically focus on the
appearance of political articles videos
and campaigns that deal with both fact
and opinion so sort of the intersection
between those two things
because that's a really interesting and
important area to focus on
while each big information kiss sharing
company has its own specific algorithms
that it's using there are certain key
elements that underlie on all of the big
companies I'm gonna focus mainly on
Google YouTube and Facebook as their
prime information sharing companies but
I'll give a sort of broad high-level
overview of how these algorithms work so
right when you're scrolling through your
Facebook feed and you're asked to sort
of donate to the up-and-coming candidate
right why are you asking why are you
being asked to donate to that candidate
as opposed to the incumbents campaign or
if you've been like binge watching one
you know political channel on YouTube I
don't know if you guys have done that
I've definitely done that while studying
for classes right
why does YouTube recommend a totally you
know a different channel that you've
never seen before and what are the
effects of those recommendations so
there are three steps basically that
companies generally follow and these are
search engine companies to take in your
data to sort through it and to give it
back to you and I want to take a look at
these three steps a little bit more
closely so we can get a sense of what's
being taken off the internet and how
that informs what's being given back to
us the first step are these spiders and
spiders are automated bots that scour
the internet looking for new or updated
information so right now there are
millions and millions of tons of data
available on the web so every single day
there are new websites and new articles
being published but different websites
are also updating information right and
we can think I think there are 20 plus
million new text or text things
published on the internet every single
day and this should not be a shocking
number right because we think of let's
say new clothing being added to clothing
website
it's your new Facebook post that new
YouTube you know video description every
single day these things need to be added
to let's say the Google database and so
we need really efficient BOTS that are
going to gather in all this information
and they work by seeking the HTML or
just however you programmed your website
taking that information and taking the
text that's in it and you know they're
really cool problems that we need to
deal with sort of how to most
effectively take in this data and
sitemaps are really important for
websites to publish sitemaps
well catalog all of the pages for any
given website so for example if I'm
searching for you know water bottles and
in Amazon's cataloging they have a page
for water bottles and that's included in
their site map that will likely be
queried up as a search response for what
I've searched language obviously is the
most important thing here so you want
really clear descriptions so that all
the words that are describing what your
content is will be picked up by the bots
stored so that it can vent eventually be
given back so Google actually recommends
two websites that rely heavily on
photographs and videos that they should
really include descriptions and their
HTML to make sure that this content is
also being included once we have all of
this information it needs to then be
sorted and that happens in a process
called indexing indexing rate is how we
process all of this data and that in
general happens in three distinct steps
I'm gonna talk about the Google model
now the first step is parsing so you
have let's say all these HTML documents
and you need to figure out what are the
titles what are the most important
things for the users to see what's the
content are their photos are is their
imagery is there a graph are there links
to other websites all of this needs to
be parsed and also there are cool
problems and this also writes a there's
a typo in the text or there's an error
in the HTML right you're partial needs
to be able to pick up on these things
and maybe even still give you the
results trying to infer what the author
meant
in addition right let's say we have all
the information parsed we need to then
barrel or organize the information and
the way barrelling works the basic idea
is that we want to take the data and
sort it into smaller areas that are
links by concept okay so if I search
Barack Obama on the internet if by
search engine was now going to go and
look at every single page that has ever
been published that would be like
incredibly complicated it would take a
long time and take up a lot of time and
a lot of space and we don't want to do
that right we want to be fast and we
want to be accurate so it might look at
a few barrels it might look at the
Barack Obama barrel maybe the president
barrel you know maybe the Michelle Obama
barrel or whatever it is but a smaller
subset of information to look through
and get the most relevant information
and I'm gonna give you an example of how
this works so this is a sentence that I
wrote pi data is a fun event great and
let's say that information is parsed
Google will give each word a word ID
these are fake ones these are just
random numbers but every word will get
an ID and that's going to be stored on a
table this table is called lexicon in in
the Google phraseology and the three
most important columns of this table is
the word itself and the word ID so for
example pie data probably is not a word
in the dictionary but it'll be given a
word ID as well as the hit list and the
hit list is going to store how many
times that word appears in the document
or in the page and this is really
important because we're gonna sort that
list by the hit list and see what are
the most important or the most commonly
occurring words and based off of that
we're gonna place the web document or
the text into a barrel so if the word
Barack Obama appears a lot of times
we're gonna say okay I know which three
barrels or which 10 barrels this needs
to go in so that's also an important
thing to realize the same web document
will go Kengo in a number of different
barrels but it's not going to be put in
write something that was mentioned only
once there's something that's not so
relevant to the overarching theme of the
text once everything is sorted into
barrels the barrels themselves are
sorted and this is really important so
we're gonna look at the hit lists now
within the barrel itself and try to
organize within that category which
pages are the most relevant and this
helps us a lot because now when a user
comes to search for Barack Obama we have
the most relevant and important text
sitting right on top and we can give
those out to the user really quickly so
great this is sort of how parameters are
taken in to the search engines all right
we're going to take the data that we're
looking at really every single second
trying to update and then we're going to
organize it but the big question is how
is that data given back to us and now
these algorithms remain quite elusive
and companies do this on purpose right
they want to remain competitive and
especially
because of all the heat that very
prominent social media companies have
been given recently no company really
wants to reveal exactly what it's doing
with your data I think this is really
interesting I think that a lot of users
don't understand how much of their
privacy of their leveraging in order to
use these three web applications but
hopefully we can gain some insight today
as to what really what's being used to
give us our ser piece which is the
search engine result pages there are two
main qualities that any algorithm is
going to look for when thinking of what
to query up as a response the most
important one is number two here
relevance right we want to take the key
words in your search and find the pages
that most accurately respond to what
you've looked for word but also you want
to have a high quality page so to give
you an example if I search for what the
weather outside is if I'm given a page
about like a conspiracy theory about how
the Sun is really a light bulb or
something so that might be very relevant
to what I'm looking for but it's
probably not a high quality page whereas
like if I search that same thing like
what's the weather outside and I get
like a really high quality article on
the cotton industry and all of its ups
and downs that might be a very reputable
article but it's not gonna be so helpful
to what I'm looking for so we want to
find a balance between these two things
so let's look at the first the first
quality which is quality right we want
to make sure that the pages that we're
giving back to our users are really good
pages and Google and specific really
focus on links to try and figure out how
reputable is this website is this text
right why does this work let's say where
a lot of research papers are published
and they're all citing the same research
paper we can assume that original
research paper is a good one because
it's being commonly linked to it's being
commonly cited so websites are going to
work in the same way if a lot of
different papers are corresponding to
the same one webpage we can assume that
that web page is actually a good one
in addition they also will look at if we
have already a pre-established good
website that's linking to your page
we'll think it's good so if Yahoo links
to your
Yahoo's very reputable they would only
post something that we know was a good
article so we're going to give them a
higher attention so I'm just gonna
briefly sort of explain this equation
how we PageRank that's the name of the
process that Google uses to figure out
the quality of a page and it looks like
this so we have some dampeners we can
ignore those for now those are just
going to make sure that the PR the
PageRank function always averages out to
one so in any closed system of web pages
where they're all linking to one another
with backlinks included we want the
average PageRank of all of those pages
to be equal to 1 and then what's inside
what terms are we looking at so all of
these T terms those are all of the pages
that link to your page ok so let's say
you're all websites and I'm my own
website if you all point to me you're
all my T's and thank you because now I'm
gonna be more reputable each of those
pages has their own PageRank so that's
going to be considered divided by the C
function the C function here looks at
how many other pages are pointing to so
if you're all pointing to me but you're
also pointing to one another that's
gonna mean like none of us stand out so
much and that'll be worse for my own
PageRank great so we're going to let's
understand this a little bit further
also you can see quite obviously we're
defining PageRank with more functions of
PageRank that seems to be a conundrum
but the way this works is it's going to
if we make a matrix with all of the
links of the different articles we can
try and determine like the eigen value
of the matrix their age histories so we
can approximate what the PageRank would
be when they all average out to one so
just looking at an example let's say we
have two pages and write a simple simple
case they only point to one another oh
yeah so in general Google uses the D as
the dampener to be 0.85 we can talk
about why they choose that number but
we're gonna use it right now for the
example if the only thing that points to
page a here is page B so we're going to
take page B and divide it by 1 right
because the only thing that page B is
pointing to is page a so the C of page B
is 1 and if we just guess right I'll
just you know for the sake of arguing
that the page rank is one if you look at
the bottom over here so we see that that
actually makes sense
the page rank of a if the page rank of B
is one we're gonna have 1 divided by 1
times 0.85 plus 0.15 that's going to be
equal to 1 the same thing is true right
if now the page rank of a is 1 we can
just substitute that right into the page
rank of B equation and they're both
going to be equal to 1 right the
averages of 2 ones is 1 and that works
but had we started off with a different
value and again I'm saying right now
guessing we would not guess we would put
this into a matrix and try to to solve
it what we would do is iterate through
each time so make a guess out with a
page rank of B would be input that into
the function for the page rank of a and
then take that result and put it into
the B and then based off of our results
we see that the average of those first
two numbers is not 1 so we're gonna move
it up a little bit more take the result
for B it put it back into a and so on
and so forth until we approximate closer
to the average being 1 right if you
really overshoot you're gonna see that
the values are going to go down if you
under suitable go up and eventually in a
closed set
we're only a points to B and B points to
a is the average of the page ranks
should be 1 but if you look at a more
complex case like this and here the math
is already done please look up this
paper it's excellent if you want to see
this for yourself where we feel like
page see a lot of pages are pointing to
it it's going to end up having a higher
page rank but the average of all of
these is still 1 so we're looking sort
of at a statistical model of this and
that's how PageRank is going to be
calculated yeah great the other thing
that we want to look at is so that's all
for the quality score PageRank is going
to give a quality score we're also going
to have a relevance score and there are
a lot of really interesting and fun
variables that go into determining the
relevance of a given page I'm just going
to look at a few interesting variables
but there are an estimated 100 like a
few hundred to a few thousand depending
on the complexity of the search engine
so we can estimate that Google has
within the low thousands of variables
that it's going to consider when
determining which of those website to
pull out of its barrel to match your
search I'll just talk about some of
these so your user history right if I
that
gonna be really important for
determining which results to query f so
if I search like food near me and every
time I search that I choose like the
lowest cost option slowly I'm only going
to see the lower costing websites
previous performance of advertisers or
content providers if we all search for
music and we consistently don't choose a
specific artist that artist is going to
have a lower relevancy score and appear
less frequently and not as close to the
top the number of ads available to be
shown or content right this this was
taken from a paper that spoke about ads
but it's true for content as well this
is sort of a motivating factor so we
have like a linear amount of things that
we can show a given user we have an
order top to bottom and we can't show
everything so even if roughly things
have similar relevance or everything
matches the keyword exactly we can't
show everything together so we need to
decide it in order obviously the time of
day is really important if I search for
the weather I want to see the weather
right now not tomorrow not yesterday the
the Advocate will okay find the
advertisers location obviously is
important if I'm here and I want to
google fun things near me I don't want
to see like ski resort in Alaska that's
not going to be so helpful match between
pages to be visited to the search item
so let's take that same example right I
search fun things to do near me in the
summer and there's a ski resort in New
York that's great but the pages that are
not matching my search term because I
said summer and that doesn't match with
winter I mean there are a number of
other ones right match between the
advertisement to the search term my
location as opposed just to the
advertisers location these and many
others are going to go into determining
the relevance score so again there's a
combination in these algorithms of
relevance and quality and those are
going to determine what I see now it's
important to note that these results are
both individualized and deterministic
and what that means here is that your
results are going to be subject to your
specific assumed circumstances based off
of those variables that we've seen but
at the same time there's a program that
calculates them so I just did this with
a friend of mine on Saturday night I was
hungry so I searched like fun where to
eat near me and I saw results that were
for dinner that didn't close I searched
this at nine o'clock they didn't close
until 11:00
were all with within walking distance of
my building my friend was in Melbourne
in Australia and she I said search the
same thing and right she saw breakfast
cafes because you know it's time
difference that were near her so the
results really are individualized and we
know this and that's helpful to us
however there's no one sitting on the
other side of the screen right trying to
guess that you're sorry this person
wanted this last one say what do I think
they're going to want this is like
baking a cake right take the ingredients
of all of your data and feed them into
these programs so hopefully that takes
away the fear factor I know if my mom is
like oh how does Amazon know what I want
it's not like someone's sitting there
and conspiring it's it's just an
algorithm so that's great I want to
speak now about how these focus really
on how these programs are very reliant
on rhetoric that's used both in the
search that you're you're entering into
your search bar as well as the the
content of the media itself so just
briefly speak about how advertisements
are ordered and how they're sold so
we're gonna look at the Google system
Adwords but other companies also have
similar means of selling advertisements
so what happens is advertisers
participate in many auctions where they
bid on keywords so if I'm a hair salon
I'm gonna probably bid on your salon or
barber shop maybe hair style or hair cut
or highlights depending on what my
services and depending on how many other
people are bidding I can you know the
price for either click per thousand or
price per click will go up or down
depending on the other people who are
bidding and all of those have to have a
relevancy scores so I could bid it you
know really really high amount but if my
product is not relevant to the the users
search it's not going to appear our
takeaway from here is that what I search
is going to have a direct correlation
between what results come up so I could
search something like you know Barack
Obama or something really nasty and put
his name in there and those results
might bring up different things but
depending on how many people are
searching with similar rhetoric the same
basic idea that's going to determine
certain things about the search results
and the
severe implications for politics I think
the clearest example speaking about how
click-through rates are really relevant
to what you're searching so
click-through is every time you have a
search result if all of us in the same
room and let's say not all of us but
like a million users click on the same
article link to the same search that
article is going to come up more than
any other so if there was like an NBA
game last night and two million of us
searched you know NBA game last night
if there are two articles written one
talks about the technique of a point
guard and one talks about this player
has a drug addiction a lot of us are
going to be more interested in the drug
addiction article and that's going to
slowly push up the relevance score so
now when more people type in NBA game
that's going to be the article that
takes the top slot now other journalists
might pick up on this and so they might
write an expose on the article or
interview other players or fans and
that's going to become all of the news
that appears when you search for the NBA
game and that article about you know the
point guards technique that might be
relegated to a search about prank art
techniques and so what should be an
equal playing field becomes no longer
becomes an equal playing field because
of our similar search patterns and how
our clicking affects the relevancy score
of a given page right and now all these
new articles that are speaking about
that you know the the big story they're
going to all link that original article
and the PageRank is just going to keep
going up and this has really significant
implications for the political sphere if
the same articles are being clicked on
about a given campaign politician issue
that's being searched for the relevancy
score is just going to continue to go up
and they're going to be new links made
between what I searched for and what
you've clicked on you being millions of
users and that's really a really
significant a good question that we need
to ask is is it actually true right if
it's the case that my Google searches
are now reflecting your preference that
general you and recommendation
algorithms are going to pick up on this
rate so YouTube is going to start giving
us the most clicks on video even if it's
not like the most directly correlated to
what I search for right these results
become more biased or influenced by
other people's
recommendation research is not so clear
that increased exposure to a given
candidate or article actually correlates
to increased favor however it is clear
that if you're in a social group that
all has the same political opinion
you're more likely to agree with an
article that you saw about then also
yeah on these pages I've linked the DOI
which like the ISBN for research so if
you like I encourage everyone to look it
up and do your own research this is
pretty interesting so you might see like
a radical article like saying something
that you did not think was intuitive at
all and you're like not so sure what you
think about it and really you just want
to like look at pictures of your friends
dogs so you're not paying attention to
your political Facebook feed but then
maybe you're at work and if someone
shares that same opinion
now you're statistically more inclined
to say oh no yeah this is a real thing
that that article I saw it was factually
correct and if this is happening let's
say everyone in this room is basically
like we're all friends we're like
interested in the same things so we
click on the same YouTube videos and
maybe a few of us like search some
politician and we watch their video now
the rest of us are going to be
recommended that same thing so it's kind
of all in our heads and if one of us in
the same digital social circle shares an
article about that that same candidate
we're all more likely to say oh this
this guy thought it was legit like it
probably is that's really interesting
because it's not based off of merit it's
based off of popularity and obviously
more and more people are getting their
information today from online sources
and digital media
so like when TV started becoming more
popular and they were more commonly
owned so this really changed the game
there was an upsurge of surge of
political campaigns being televised and
we would think maybe this social media
outbreak and phenomenon would have
similar results but in fact we see it's
much more severe firstly right as
accessible as televisions were if you
have a computer or a phone you can see
information much more quickly and it's
much more accessible to you but more
than that you're still painting with
broad strokes if you just have a TV
campaign you can kind of guess out what
the average American would want to see
but all Americans are going to see it
that have a TV if you're
using recommendation algorithms and
you're targeting small pieces of the
demographic that are statistically
inclined to agree with your message
you're able to target their newsfeed and
Facebook and YouTube and until recently
Twitter allows you to do that so like
we're targeting much more specific
demographics and that can severely
influence the political opinions that
are going to be made so if you're in a
digital social group and everyone is
sharing similar pages you might never
even see the other side even if what
you're searching for is in theory not a
biased search and this this is this is a
huge implication so the CTR the
click-through rate that I mentioned
before will directly increase this is
we've mentioned this basically the
relevance of a given website so the more
it's clicked on the higher it'll be in
your search results and that obviously
is a really cyclical process so if
you're clicking on something that's
going to become important more people
are going to see it because it's higher
even more people will click on it and
it'll raise even higher in this process
only continues so I'll tell you sort of
why I became interested in this and why
I think it's really important to look at
sort of how would the search engine the
makeup of the search engine influences
how these political opinions are being
formed and the the political and
psychological research done on similar
topics I was in a class I'm gonna keep
this very apolitical but my professor
was like really talking about how great
the green New Deal is so I don't know so
much about it but he really was like
this is the best thing ever and he he
had a very I thought dramatic way of
challenging the class he said does
anyone think there's a price too high to
pay to save the world so that's that's a
really interesting argument to make in
favor of this paper and so I'm not even
knowing that much but having seen some
articles wasn't specifically trying to
challenge the green New Deal I raise my
hands to that question which was like
whatever but I said like I don't think
that people not everyone who opposes
this paper opposes it because you know
they think it's so horrible they just
think maybe there are more economical
ways maybe there are different ways to
approach the climate issue and
some people in my class turned around
and they were like Tamar thinks climate
change is a hoax that's not what I said
but this this rhetoric is is not you
know this is not a special story and I
don't know if any of you have had this
experience but it shouldn't be crazy to
us why this is happening if this is a
true phenomenon where click-through
rates increase your relevancy score if
you're a smart journalist you know that
if you have sort of like a hot topic or
you can use some strong rhetoric that'll
increase your click-through rates you
know you should be more inclined to use
stronger language and maybe enticing
your attractive phraseology clickbait as
it's called and you want right you want
the bots to pick up on this language
that will slowly become the top results
in people's newsfeeds and in their
search results and strong rhetoric
oftentimes can lead to really radicalize
conversation and if you've seen the word
evil horrible crooked I don't know all
these words that are thrown around in
the political sphere anyone who
challenges you they're really going to
be there they're going to be radical in
your minds most probably and this this
is crazy I mean that's I think directly
what what caused my my event and I don't
think this is exclusive to me and this
obviously I'm sure you read about and
heard about in the news but it's
important so sort of a broader question
that I want to ask just sort of trying
to sum and think about this right if
it's true
that using radical speech can actually
increase your exposure to users and
you're able to even target users that
are inclined to agree with those
messages we have to ask like if you're
only seeing parts of the story and these
programs are designed for you to only
speak part of the story as they exist
now who's doing the wrong thing and this
is like a symbiotic or symmetry otic
maybe a relationship between companies
that are giving out media users who are
benefiting from this media and right the
search engine companies that are making
that connection and benefiting off the
result so right we have to ask if us as
users are we a customers or are with
commodities because we're seeing more
what we want to see right different news
companies journalists outlets there
reaching more of their demographic there
they're getting more of the users that
want to see their information and Google
or YouTube or Facebook is benefiting off
that pairing and right these companies
are incentivized to have users be
interested in what they're seeing
because then users will spend more time
on the websites they can charge more for
ads and don't forget that also these
advertisers are using these same
algorithms to to get you and so this is
like a really intense problem but no
one's unhappy with it specifically and
we want to maybe ask is this the best
practice as a room of data users we're
like fortunately a lot of us or a lot of
you are being very innovative in terms
of what we can do with Sita it's an
important question to ask like what are
the the real implications how much is
this going to impact our political
future and I think that's so cool that
it's it's voting day today because a lot
of voters hopefully you all and a lot of
young voters are going to be informed by
these political articles that they're
seeing and hopefully make informed
decisions but the the cards are kind of
stacked against them there are questions
of government regulation being involved
in this process obviously in the past
few weeks Facebook and Twitter have
visited Congress and have really been
put under scrutiny questioning if these
this targeted demographic system with
considering these variables and
increasing relevancy scores as they do
is actually the right thing also if you
have answers to these questions please
let me know I think it's been great to
sort of realize how the search engines
are influencing the psychological and
political papers I am hoping to model
this in some formal way there have been
some interesting like preliminary
studies trying to analyze like the
proliferation of clickbait but if you
have ideas on that I would also love to
hear them that's all I have to say thank
you so much and if you have questions
please feel free to ask
[Applause]
wait so I think that's a great diagram
and it's like it's nobody's fault
er it kind of sucks right so what are we
don't pain and it seems like that system
described it's just sort of like a
equilibrium point right and like if
that's not a result that we as a society
want to see then it would seem like they
would need to be like bored you know in
there or something that introduces some
other effect in theirs to shift that
equilibrium point and the only thing I
can think of is it becomes like I mean
this is maybe sounds terrible but in a
way in this case you're giving people
what they want and this is what happens
you know like so sometimes there's that
role for an editorial injection of
content or something where it's like
maybe you know you have to wear some
sort of like editorial or you know
expert could say even though here are
the sort of naturally ranked by the
algorithm results we're going to inject
this content
[Music]
it's a great question and it's one that
people are really struggling to answer
now I'll say like these companies the
search engine companies are usually
private and so sort of introducing any
sort of government regulation can be a
great challenge and can directly drive
down revenue so if you're seeing more of
what you don't want to see you're less
likely to be on the page and any
advertiser is able to see that I don't
know the answer
I know arguments that that companies
have made against having that be the
case Mark Zuckerberg last week was
saying like it's not Facebook's job to
verify the factual accuracy of any given
campaign users should be able to do that
but right as we've discussed they might
be blinded from doing that any
regulation is going to worsen the
experience for one if not all of the
three nodes in this so I don't have the
answers but it's a good question to
think about yeah
definitely relevance its relied on more
heavily but if we only looked at quality
and let's say direct relevance so really
how similar is your search to the thing
that's going to appear without
considering other variables and
specifically without considering what a
lot of other people are looking at that
could really change the nature of what
becomes current events because if you
know if you see all of the things that
are happening and not only one or two of
the main stories that would be a lot
better for seeing different sides of the
story I will say like in Google's credit
they have said that in there like top
news section when you search for
something that is they'll like go back
to the same like Wall Street Journal New
York Times a few standard what's it
called institution Shore news
institutions and they won't consider
these variables but I mean that doesn't
hold up for like as you're scrolling
down but quality is actually I think the
best thing if you're not only seeing you
know one article linking to you know one
sort of chain of articles but really
like in general people are linking
opposing positions and like positions
and trying to get a full scope of an
article then we might see things which
are more evenly balanced yeah
interesting so I mean yeah how would you
suggest
oh yeah like I think the question of
linking is good like in general you
would like to think in the case let's
say the case of a research papers if
there's one paper that continually is
quoted you think that one is reputable
but as you said write a biased article
could link to a bias article that
supports them so it seems to be no you
can be really conscious of your cookies
so sort of what websites are able to
keep track of where you've been and keep
reading past like the first results and
if you see something that that's
strongly in favor of of any one side or
uses really extreme rhetoric could be
conscious I mean I think that's like a
general life rule never trust anyone
that's too impassioned or just be
thorough and yeah I don't know yeah
building yeah so we would have to really
restructure search engines in general
because if only the New York Times did
it they would lose out and the Wall
Street Journal or other companies that
have also personalized method methods of
getting you to see their Hot Topic
topics right that company would lose so
this would you need to bring a lot of
people to the table I think really
changing the way that ads if ads weren't
like based off of demographic but we're
really only based off of search terms I
think that would be a lot better and
yeah
so I'll just repeat the question like
what happens if you're in multiple
social groups and you're not only seeing
the information from one but from a
collection so I think that would be
great and that would probably confuse
algorithms I mean hopefully we have
friends with varying opinions so that
would be excellent but I know it's not
always the case but I mean there's no
way to formalize that like make everyone
have friends with different opinions but
I think that would be great
digitally and in general right have a
diverse group yeah so yeah like Big
Brother is definitely a approach that
different societies have taken like okay
let's just take away what this person
said it seems to not be America's model
sort of a freedom of speech thing but
there's some really interesting research
papers if you want to come over
afterwards I can show you that actually
try to write programs that can figure
out when something is clickbait so
whether it's like really extreme
language that's like you would only use
it to attract users or seeing if the
title actually correlates to the
information like is the title delivering
factually on its claim in the title but
I don't know that I am like advocating
for a less freedom of speech based
society okay I think we're out of time
but thank you so much everyone for
coming I hope you enjoy your day
[Applause]